zone Europe sur sensation bonjour et
bienvenue dans zone Europe sur Radio
sensation et sur TV 78 une émission
spéciale enregistrée à Madrid en Espagne
voici le sommaire un traité d'amitié et
de coopération entre la France et
l'Espagne a été récemment signé quels en
sont les objectifs rencontrent avec
Stéphane vogeta député de la cinquième
circonscription des Français de
l'étranger l'Espagne est membre de
l'Union européenne aujourd'hui 86% des
Espagnols se sentent citoyens de l'Union
européenne Juan cuesta président
d'Europe en plus sera notre invité
l'Espagne
occupe la 36e place sur 180 pays dans le
classement mondial pour la liberté de la
presse établie par Reporters sans
frontières nous ferons le point avec
Pilar Bernal vice-présidente de RSF
Espagne le tourisme en Espagne le pays a
accueilli plus de 71 millions de
visiteurs l'an dernier dont un peu plus
de 6 millions à Madrid nous verrons les
atouts de la capitale espagnole
[Musique]
280 000 espagnols vivent en France et
150 000 Français vivent en Espagne les
relations entre les deux pays sont
anciennes cette année le traité signé
entre les deux États à Barcelone a pour
objectif de les accélérer à l'image des
traités signés avec l'Allemagne et
l'Italie on fait le point sur les
relations franco-espagnoles avec le
député Stéphane vogeta
bonjour Stéphane
Europe vous êtes depuis 2021 député des
Français établis hors de France de la
5ème circonscription donc des Français
vivants en Espagne au Portugal à Andorre
et aussi à Monaco la France et l'Espagne
ont donc signé un traité d'amitié et de
coopération visant à renforcer leurs
liens alors on peut le comparer à
d'autres traités comme celui
d'Aix-la-Chapelle en 2019 le traité
franco-allemand mais aussi celui le
traité franco-italien du kérinal en 2021
alors en tant que député vous avez suivi
de presse ce dossier à quoi sert ce
traité d'amitié entre les deux états
français et espagnol
d'abord c'est un traité qui vient
culminer une trajectoire de
rapprochement et d'amélioration des
relations entre la France et l'Espagne
la France et l'Espagne ont une histoire
un peu compliquée notamment à l'époque
de la dictature espagnole il y avait une
grande mésentente entre les deux pays et
même durant la phase de transition
démocratique de l'Espagne il y avait à
l'époque là encore une mésentente
notamment au niveau agricole au niveau
également de la sécurité intérieure avec
la France qui donnait trop souvent
l'accueil à des terroristes en tout cas
présumés comme tel membre de l'état de
l'Etat en Espagne donc depuis une
trentaine d'années une quarantaine
d'années on a vraiment vu une
amélioration des relations bilatérales
et je pense que ce traité qui vient
juste qui venait juste un an après le
sommet de Montauban en 2021 et bien
permis vraiment de démontrer au monde
entier à quel point l'axe
franco-espagnol est devenu un axe
prépondérant en Europe alors vous étiez
présent le 19 janvier 203 lorsque ce
traité a été signé donc à Barcelone un
choix pas un anodin il y a là-bas la
plus grande communauté française
d'Espagne et c'est aussi la BAC il y a
eu des végalités un petit peu
indépendantistes ces dernières années
qui se sont calmées c'était pas un
hasard Barcelone non c'était pas un
hasard barcelone est une ville
magnifique et effectivement qui
accueille une grande partie des Français
qui ont choisi de vivre en Espagne et
effectivement la ville de Barcelone a
été choisie également aussi bien par la
par l'Espagne que par la France pour
démontrer que une page s'était refermée
qu'on avait tourné la page des troubles
indépendantistes qui avaient fait
beaucoup de mal à l'attractivité de de
la Catalogne et de Barcelone en
particulier et là grâce à ce sommet on a
pu remettre Barcelone au centre du jeu
au centre de la scène des relations
bilatérales et donc du jeu européen mais
je pense que aussi bien le gouvernement
français que le gouvernement espagnol
s'en réjouissait énormément alors ce
traité il a pour vocation dynamiser les
échanges politiques entre les deux pays
il y aura désormais
sommet franco-espagnol chaque année
alternativement en France et en Espagne
des ministres pourront également
assister régulièrement au Conseil des
ministres du pays voisin alors à quoi ça
peut servir c'est rapprochement
politique à peser davantage ensemble
dans l'Union européenne et à défendre
les intérêts communs des deux pays je
pense que c'est un reflet d'abord comme
vous l'avez dit c'est seulement le
troisième traité de ce genre après le
traité d'amitié avec l'Allemagne puis
celui avec l'Italie signé en 2021
seulement le troisième traité d'amitié
bilatérale et et en s'assurant ainsi de
la compénétration de nos de nos
institutions et de nos de nos instances
du gouvernance politique on s'assure
également que nos positions seront
alignées et il est important que les
positions de la France et de l'Espagne
soient alignées ou en tout cas qu'on ait
le temps de travailler en amont sur nos
positions que ce soit sur la défense sur
l'agriculture sur le commerce sur la
politique extérieure parce que il finit
l'axe franco-espagnol devient un axe de
plus en plus prépondérant en Europe il
vous aura pas échappé que l'axe
franco-allemand c'est un peu affaibli
l'axe franco-britannique avec visite a
disparu l'idée alternatives d'autres
s'appuyer sur d'autres pays que
forcément l'Allemagne qui parfois
c'est parfois compliqué on le sait en
fonction des différents années avec
l'Allemagne alors que on a évidemment
une vocation d'amitié à très long terme
avec l'Allemagne mais ceci dit il est
bon d'avoir des relais il est bon de ne
pas marcher sur une seule jambe et avec
l'Espagne je pense qu'on a une deuxième
jambe très solide d'autant plus que
l'Espagne et à la fois de notre premier
client et notre premier notre premier
fournisseur donc il est important qu'on
puisse travailler ensemble en amont et
que effectivement on puisse donc avoir
cette représentation de la France dans
le conseil des ministres espagnols et
vice-versa je voudrais qu'on parle de la
défense maintenant alors la coopération
en matière de défense entre la France et
l'Espagne c'est surtout le Scaff le
système donc de combat aérien du futur
qui remplacera le futur rafale alors il
y a l'Allemagne aussi dans le projet la
Belgique qui l'a rejoint récemment cette
année alors chaque année aura lieu un
conseil de défense également
franco-espagnol la France et l'Espagne
ont des comment notamment en Afrique du
Nord et en Méditerranée effectivement
l'axe défense du traité de coopération
du traité d'amitié et fondamental et
fondamental et il est surtout basé sur
les aspects industriels à l'évidence il
faut que nous avions avec l'Espagne une
position commune vis-à-vis de notre
politique extérieure politique de
défense notamment en termes de soutien à
l'Ukraine dans le conflit actuel mais il
est également très important qu'il y ait
une collaboration au niveau européen qui
se développe afin de que nous puissions
développer des technologies des outils
des armements qui soient interopérables
entre nos armées il n'y a pas encore
d'armée européenne il y aura peut-être
une un jour et pour l'instant on a des
armées nationales mais qui sont appelés
à mener peut-être à collaborer et à être
ensemble sur des terrains d'action dans
l'avenir et il est important que dans ce
cadre là elle puisse partager des
technologies compatibles et le mieux
c'est de partager une technologie
européenne plutôt que les technologies
alternatives qui sont souvent souvenies
par nos panneaux concurrents alors vous
êtes entrepreneur donc vous imaginez que
vous êtes sensible à ces chiffres aux
chiffres des échanges économiques
franco-espagnol vous l'avez dit la
France et le premier partenaire
économique de l'Espagne qui est lui le
quatrième client de la France en 2021
les échanges bilatéraux de bien entre
les deux pays ont atteint leur niveau
record
78,2 milliards d'euros ces échanges ce
qu'ils devront encore croître à l'avenir
se selon vous c'est la suite logique ah
je pense qu'ils ne feront que croître à
l'avenir c'est logique entre deux pays
qui se ressemblent et qui sont
complémentaires en termes industriel en
terme agricole notamment c'est logique
aussi puisqu'on partage une frontière et
que de plus en plus on va avoir des
interconnexions énergétiques
interconnexion de données interconnexion
ferroviaire routière qui vont
s'améliorer qui ont donné de meilleures
infrastructures pour permettre là encore
d'améliorer cette cette interaction
commerciale et à partir de là et bien il
est fondamental notamment et c'est
notamment ce qui est un lié également le
traité d'amitié d'avoir chaque année là
encore une sorte de sommet économique ou
auquel participeront notamment le Medef
et son homologue espagnol
pour finir Stéphane Vegeta parlons
maintenant de ce projet de gazoduc
l'énergie c'est devenu un sujet très
important primordial pour l'Europe
depuis la guerre en Ukraine il y a un
projet donc de gaz duc entre Barcelone
et Marseille les deux pays vont
construire un tuyau sous la Méditerranée
pour transporter l'hydrogène vert cela
devrait aboutir environ aux alentours de
2030 l'objectif donc envoyer d'hydrogène
vert vers l'Europe du Nord vers
l'Allemagne notamment pour faire
fonctionner son son industrie cela sera
important pour les objectifs du pacte
vert européen l'Espagne le Portugal
aussi veulent devenir les champions de
cette énergie verte du futur exactement
c'est important pour ces objectifs c'est
aussi important pour les objectifs de la
France de notre gouvernement de
décarboner l'énergie française c'est
pour ça qu'il y a eu une petite
mésentente avec l'Espagne qui il y a
encore un an souhaitait que l'on remette
sur la table le projet 1004 qui était un
gazoduc qui allait passer sous les
Pyrénées et qu'elle est transportée du
gaz naturel gaz naturel qui pourrait
être importés
sous forme liquéfier par l'Espagne et
ensuite envoyer vers le nord de l'Europe
et notamment l’allemagne qu'elle avait
bien besoin suite au blocage de gaz Prom
en l'occurrence avec la France on a dû
être ferme pour dire non à une
infrastructure qui ne contribuerait pas
au décarbonate de notre économie en
revanche on a ouvert la porte soutenu
par l'Europe pour sur le fait que l'on
construit des infrastructures qui
permettront effectivement d'aborder une
manière conjointe l'énergie du futur et
l'énergie du futur c'était un hydrogène
vert un hydrogène produit grâce à des
sources d'électricité renouvelables
vertes en Espagne l'Espagne qui sera un
producteur de ce de cette source
d'énergie et exportateur à partir de
2030 2035 et donc à ce moment-là la
France pourra importer de l'hydrogène
vert et je pense que ce serait une bonne
nouvelle aussi bien pour la France que
pour l'Espagne merci beaucoup Stéphane
Végéta d'avoir été avec nous merci à
vous je rappelle donc que vous êtes
député des Français établis en Espagne
au Portugal à Andorre et à Monaco
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis le 1er juillet Madrid dirige les
débats politiques de l'UE et ce jusqu'à
la fin de l'année quelle priorité quels
enjeux on en parle avec Juan questar
président de repas
espagnol
la l'Espagne dirige aujourd'hui la
présidence du Conseil de l'Union
européenne nous allons parler avec vous
Juan des priorités de l'Espagne pour
l'Europe lors de ce semestre commençons
avec le pacte migratoire c'est un sujet
qui concerne beaucoup l'Espagne mucho
espagnol
veut mettre l'accent car comme
l'ensemble des pays de la mer
Méditerranée nous sommes parmi les plus
touchés par cette immigration
incontrôlée
depuis longtemps mais on arrive pas à
voir le filon solidaire des partenaires
européens c'est terriblement difficile
d'arriver à ce qu'il s'engage tous
solidairement pour répartir les demandes
d'asile car on ne peut pas continuer
comme ça que les pays d'arriver doivent
assumer tout ce coup cette attention et
cette intégration
cependant il y a eu une avancée
importante avec des chiffres sur la
table pour que les pays qui ne veulent
pas assumer leur quotas de réfugiés
solidairement et bien paye pour aider
les pays qui acceptent de les accueillir
le solidariamente
una cantina
c'est appareillage mais cela est évident
qu'il faut travailler à l'échelle
européenne pour trouver les solutions il
faut se battre contre les politiques
restrictives des forces d'extrême droite
qui influencent chaque fois plus les
gouvernements européens
il faudrait contrôler l'immigration il
faut faire une politique à la source il
faut assumer solidairement les réfugiés
qui arrivent et il faut être généreux
on a été très généreux avec les réfugiés
Ukrainiens on en a accueilli plus de 4
millions
nous pourrions faire un effort je ne dis
pas similaire mais dans le fond un grand
effort pour en accueillir d'autres
arrivant de Libye ou d'autres endroits
de la planète
Espana l'Espagne a aussi un lien
particulier avec l'Amérique latine elle
veut profiter de cette présidente du
Conseil de l'UE pour avancer plus sur
les relations changer les relations avec
le continent sud-américain il y a aussi
l'accord de libre-échange avec le
Mercosur qui est très très compliqué
de commerce avec le Mercosur
cela fait des années et ce n'est pas
toujours terminé je crois que vous en
savez quelque chose en France des
raisons pour lesquelles ce dossier
traîne depuis longtemps
je crois qu'il y a eu des initiatives
mais pas une forte volonté politique de
rétablir les relations entre ces deux
régions entre l'Union européenne et
l'Amérique latine
nous les avons délaissé un peu et pas
seulement l'Union européenne l'Espagne
aussi et cela me fait énormément de mal
ce sont nos frères ce sont des gens avec
qui on partage une culture similaire une
langue c'est un immense potentiel une
richesse énorme et nous l'avons vu
maintenant lorsque l'Union européenne a
essayé aux Nations Unies de condamner
l'invasion russes en Ukraine nous avons
vu les pays d'Amérique latine s'abstenir
que faut-il en penser
demandons-nous que nous avons nous pas
fait pour en arriver à ce genre de
situation
je crois que les autorités européennes
et espagnoles ont fait leur autocritique
de ce que nous avons mal fait et de ce
que nous aurions dû faire nous allons
retracer ce chemin erratique et nous
allons donner une impulsion à ces
relations je pense que l'Amérique latine
a besoin du soutien de l'Union
européenne et vice et versa et de cela
peut sortir de bonnes choses de grands
accomplissements et des bénéfices pour
tous
bénéfice
autre priorité autre thème important en
ce moment c'est la réindustrialisation
de l'Europe nous avons vu lors de ces
dernières années la faiblesse de secteur
comme l'énergie ou la santé aussi c'est
une priorité de plus pour se semestre
et c'est une priorité évidemment une des
idées lancées par la présidente
espagnole ce qui s'appelle l'autonomie
stratégique ouverte désormais on parle
d'autonomie stratégique en pensant au
matériel de défense
après aussi la présidence de Donald
Trump aux États-Unis et bien il a essayé
de dissoudre l'Union européenne dans
l'OTAN et toutes les autres choses qui
lui passaient par la tête donc au vu de
cette attitude nous avons vu que
l'autonomie stratégique devait être
promu par l'Union européenne
mais ensuite la covid est arrivée la
guerre est arrivée nous nous sommes
rendus compte que nous sommes dépendants
en matière d'énergie en matière
sanitaire
partant de Saint nous avons lancé
l'Union européenne de la santé nous
avons vu notre dépendance dans plusieurs
domaines et de cela je pense qui est né
une idée joyeuse
récupérée impulser une nouvelle
autonomie stratégique ouverte dans tous
ces domaines pas seulement dans la
défense l'énergie bien sûr
nous étions dépendant de la Russie la
santé aussi nous nous étions rendu
compte que nous ne fabriquions pas de
masque ni de respirateur nous devions
les trouver en Chine tout cela il faut
le résoudre et l'Espagne veut aussi dans
ce concept d'autonomie stratégique
ouverte donner une nouvelle impulsion et
dans le domaine de la
réindustrialisation c'est clair que
c'est quelque chose que nous avions déjà
depuis quelques années abandonné
je sais pas si de force une fois j'ai
entendu à Bruxelles qu'il disait que
globalement l'industrie s'était en Chine
l'innovation c'était aux États-Unis
l'agriculture c'était en Amérique latine
et en Afrique et l'Europe ce qui restait
à l'Europe le pacte climatique
et cela est un problème sérieux je pense
que le pacte industriel le plan qui a
Ursula vanderlingen est justement pour
donner un autre chemin une impulsion à
l'industrie européenne c'est clair que
les êtres d'État pour lesquelles nous
avons promis de participer comme l'ont
fait d'autres pays comme les États-Unis
ou la Chine sans aller plus loin car ils
vont se heurter semble-t-il à la
discipline budgétaire qu'il semble que
nous ayons encore essayé de récupérer
après la covid
ici miramos et si l'on regarde pour
finir les sondages on voit que les
Espagnols sont l'un des peuples qui se
sentent le plus européen comment peut-on
l'expliquer comment c'est pour expliquer
je pense que depuis le temps de la
dictature
l'Europe pour nous est une référence de
liberté c'est la vocation des Espagnols
passer les Pyrénées et respirer je crois
que cela est un peu resté dans le
subconscient
l'Europe c'est la liberté et ça a
toujours été notre vocation
lorsque Franco est mort récupérer les
libertés les Espagnols sont parvenus à
entrer dans l'Union européenne l'année
1986 pour nous c'était la fête c'était
une fête parce que nous pouvions
dialoguer au même niveau avec nos
voisins européens et nous pouvions
bénéficier de la solidarité européenne
c'est quelque chose que l'Espagne a pu
voir il n'y a pas de pont de
bibliothèque de station de chemin de fer
d'autoroute de marché de lycée collège
qui ne porte pas une plaque indiquant
qu'ils ont été réalisés avec des fonds
européens
même les professeurs de formation
professionnelle touchent leur salaire de
fonds européens cela ce sont des choses
que les Espagnols savent
après pour ceux qui se questionnent ils
disent voyons ce qui se passe quand les
Espagnols sont au guichets automatiques
ils mettent la carte le guichet
automatique c'est l'Europe et ils
mettent la carte et il n'y a plus
d'argent parce que l'Espagne a relevé
son niveau et il y a d'autres pays qui
sont entrés avec moins de revenus et il
a fallu les aider voyons comment se
porte l'européisme des Espagnols et bien
malgré ça il reste très haut les
Européens auxquels vous faisiez
référence lorsqu'on demande où elle est
plus loin c'est des quelles compétences
de souveraineté à l'Union européenne
dans n'importe quel domaine les
Espagnols sont le pourcentage le plus
nombreux qui veulent céder des
compétences de souveraineté à l'Union
européenne
j'espère qu'on avance vers cela et que
les voix qui veulent relationnaliser ce
que préconise surtout l'extrême droite
ici et dans n'importe quel autre pays
européen ne parviendront pas à cet
objectif
d'avoir été avec nous dans un Europe je
rappelle donc que vous êtes le président
de repas ensuma
[Musique]
reporters Sans Frontières sort chaque
année son classement de la liberté de la
presse en 2023 le meilleur élève de l'UE
c'est l'Irlande à la deuxième place la
Grèce elle fait office de cancre des 27
à la 107e position entre les deux la
France
occupe la 24e place et l'Espagne et 36e
on en discute avec Pilar Bernal
journaliste espagnol vice-présidente de
Reporters sans frontières en Espagne
pour Telecinco une chaîne en Espagne
vous êtes donc vice-président de
Reporters sans frontières Espagne cette
année RF a mis l'accent sur la
désinformation
et s'inquiète des dernières mesures sur
Twitter notamment et aussi de
l'apparition de l'intelligence
artificielle est-ce que ce sont des
sujets sur lesquels on s'inquiète
également ici en Espagne oui parce que
la de ces informations sur menace et
globale et aujourd'hui on le voit par
rapport à la guerre en Russie et il y a
des sarmées des trolls qui essayent des
faire plus toxiques
dans tout l'Europe et ici en Espagne et
il y a un certain climat et toxique dans
les réseaux sociaux
et sociaux et donc c'est très important
et une éducation médiatique et pour que
les citoyens peuvent
résister et cette sorte des puissances
et toxiques des de la description et
aujourd'hui on on parle tout le temps de
la guerre c'est très proche de nous
d'être très proche des frontières de
l'Union européenne mais on ne doit pas
oublier la guerre hybride et qui cause
la la désim formation et
cet outil est ce type de guerre mais se
déclare pas mais et continue et ce
menace claire pour pour les pour les
démocraties c'est pour ça que et d'une
partie la la les sources de autorité et
qui sont les journalistes comme garantie
des qualités et d'autres et il faut
il faut penser que la laisser formation
est
débiles et fait plus faible la
démocratie et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
et éduquer
d'une façon médiatique et éducation
médias et en général et ça c'est un Toby
canissu
important ici en Espagne aujourd'hui le
pays ici est classé 36e au classement
des pays sur le classement RSF de la
liberté de la presse cette année donc la
liberté de la presse est considérée
comme plutôt bonne en Espagne quelles
sont les efforts à faire justement bon
en Espagne Espagne et dans les
dans les 36
meilleurs pays de classement mondial des
reporters sans frontières et c'est pas
mal mais
c'est vrai que on a on a
on a Fally et 4 postes
rétrogradé de quatre places oui on a un
rétrogradé et quatre places et ça c'est
parce que l'inverse l'environnement
médiatique en Espagne et c'est assez
toxique avec beaucoup de polarisations
et politiques et c'est pas normal dans
des centres dans des autres pays et qui
est tous les médias soif et tellement
idéologies et l'information c'est cher
l'opinion c'est pas cher et ici en
Espagne malheureusement on est on est
devant
beaucoup des médias avec beaucoup de
est trop peu d'informations et ça c'est
un problème et
en plus et il y a en concentration
médiatique assez importante surtout dans
l'audiovisuel et et ça
joue toujours contre les pluralismes et
si tu trouves et là on est en campagne
électorale et ça se voit très très
clairement et si tu as des des
adversaires et qui se battent aussi dans
les dans les seuls médiatiques dans les
dans l'espace médiatique et évidemment
la la l'opinion publique et moins et
moins pluriel et moi livre moi critique
et pour se construire c'est ses propres
et avis l'Espagne a aussi des liens
particuliers avec l'Amérique latine
là-bas la liberté de la presse c'est
encore un petit peu plus compliqué quels
sont les liens que vous entretenez avec
vos homologues latinos américains et on
aimerait latine et
la plupart des pays et plus dangereux
pour être journaliste sont là-bas et
donc
si tu vas au Mexique au béninois au
nicarawa même la Colombie et il y a
beaucoup de journalistes en danger et
des on essaye
de reporter sans frontières Espagne et
faire en sorte des ports d'entrée et
pour cette collègues
ont en danger vous accueillez donc des
journalistes latinos américains ici en
Espagne oui et il vient et quand ils
sont dans une situation critique il
vient pour trois mois il se repose il
retrouve la lame les substances
psychologiques les soutiens économiques
aussi parce qu'il faut pas oublier qui
est dans cette paille et les
journalistes et aussi
un métier très précaire et
pas très professionnel et dans pour
certains et personne et donc c'est
important pour pour eux de les soutenir
avec une économiquement et
psychologiquement et on a créé ici en
Espagne avec certains universités à un
concept qui s'appelle espace sur pour
les journalistes donc il vient pour
partager avec des étudiants et aussi
c'est cette expérience et sa
connaissance du métier etc et voilà on
travaille aussi avec les la mer à Madrid
et Barcelone Sarah Rosa et on essaye de
les soutenir parce que vraiment la
liberté de presse dans des pays et qui
qui fasse le contrôle très dur et comme
la aujourd'hui maintenant la nicara
nicarau mais Cuba au Venezuela aussi et
qui fait son contrôle s'insur et et
aussi
mettre dans en prison et cette
professionnelle ben ils sont mes soins
de
aides qui ont essayé et des de les
donner alors vous le savez pillar
l'Espagne a pris la la présidence du
Conseil de l'Union européenne de juillet
jusqu'à donc fin décembre est-ce que
cette relation entre donc l'Espagne et
l'Amérique latine va-t-elle être mise en
avant pour améliorer les relations entre
l'Union européenne et l'Amérique latine
je suis sûr et c'est un des principaux
objectifs de la présidence espagnole et
il fait ces 8 ans et qu'il y avait pas
une rencontre entre les pays des l'Union
européenne les pays de l'Amérique du Sud
et ça va arriver et moitié juillet à
Bruxelles et c'est
des priorités absolues du gouvernement
espagnol il s'essaye de
d'être et les ponts entre l'Union
européenne et l'Amérique du Sud et
il s'insiste et
dans l'idée de quai et la société est
latino américaine et les sociétés et
européennes sont les plus compatibles
les deux régions les plus compatibles et
du monde par rapport aux valeurs
aux libertés aux
différentes valeurs et ils vont essayer
faire cette Liam et endure aussi et
cette Lienne est pénale
la dernièrement il y a juste deux
semaines la présidence la précédente de
la Commission européenne donc cela a été
en Amérique du Sud et aussi parce que
les ressources naturelles c'est une
région où il y a beaucoup de ressources
naturelles et dans un contexte
géopolitique Monique et ce qui est vive
maintenant en Europe avec la guerre
voilà c'est c'est très important aussi
les litumes et des ressources naturelles
comme comme merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle donc que vous êtes
vice-présidente de reporter sans
frontières en Espagne
[Musique]
en 2022 l'Espagne a reçu
71,6 millions de touristes étrangers
parmi eux 6 millions on choisit la
capitale Madrid pourquoi venir ici j'ai
rendez-vous avec Laora navarita la
directrice marketing de destination
Madrid
on va commencer avec les atouts
touristiques de Madrid quels sont-ils
pourquoi venir à Madrid
aux besoins des touristes en quête de
différentes formes de loisirs de
divertissement d'art de patrimoine de
gastronomie de sport que la ville peut
offrir
Madrid est immense et ce que nous
cherchons c'est que les touristes qui
arrivent dans la ville profitent de la
vie et de toutes ces activités qu'il
participe avec les habitants aux
activités de la ville elle publie
colocal qui participait
[Musique]
de voir que les touristes mettent Madrid
en valeur surtout le style de tourisme
que nous visons les touristes qui
viennent de loin parce qu'au final ils
augmentent leur séjour moyen dans la
ville et ajoute également de la valeur à
l'activité touristique
qu'est-ce qu'on peut découvrir ici quels
sont les lieux à ne pas rater à visiter
absolument
à la culture historique de la vie la la
les musées sont très connus c'est ce
qu'on appelle le triangle d'or de l'art
c'est vrai que chaque jour des musées
plus petits prennent davantage
d'importance ils ont leur charme
particulier car ils sont soit dédiés à
un artiste soit dédié à une œuvre
particulière et sont comme beaucoup plus
recherchés et beaucoup plus difficile à
découvrir
le report s'oppose
ensuite bien sûr Madrid est une ville
ouverte qui permet de profiter de la
nature nous avons été désignés pour la
troisième année consécutive la ville la
plus arborée et cela est cohérent avec
notre slogan Madrid c'est la vie
on peut profiter de la ville aussi
depuis des endroits un peu touristiques
à la fin tout est lié comme nous l'avons
dit à cet art à cette culture à ce
patrimoine à cette gastronomie car au
final nous la pression toujours
de quelques tapas dans un bar au coin de
la rue de des 22 restaurants étoiles et
Michelin que nous avons à Madrid ajouté
à toute l'offre culturelle que nous
avons il y a les événements musicaux et
sportifs le shopping est aussi un atout
reconnu du tourisme dans la ville
c'est 6 millions de touristes étrangers
en 2022 qu'est-ce que ça pèse
économiquement pour la ville j'imagine
que ça a une importance
mais elle nous a montré qu'il y avait
beaucoup d'entreprises qui vivaient
grâce au tourisme par exemple les
blanchisseries et bien on a vu qu'elles
ont fermé parce qu'elles dépendaient des
clients des hôtels et de tout ce secteur
d'affaires à la fin c'est quand on perd
quelque chose que l'on remarque
l'importance qu'à pour nous le tourisme
notre rôle est de continuer à apporter
notre contribution à la ville continuer
à ce que le tourisme et la ville
coexistent dans un espace convivial pour
tous et aussi de favoriser la
décentralisation des zones afin qu'au
final nous puissions tous profiter d'une
ville en harmonie
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle donc
que vous êtes directrice marketing de
destination Madrid
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rendez-vous à présent à la Casa des
Velasquez une institution française
basée à Madrid et consacrée aux arts et
aux sciences nous rejoignons Nancy
Berthier à les professeurs des
universités à la Sorbonne spécialiste en
cinéma hispanique et c'est la première
femme directrice de la Casa de Velasquez
[Musique]
c'est pas ça
Nancy Berthier bonjour bonjour merci de
nous accueillir ici donc à la Casa de
Velasquez un lieu rempli d'histoire
important pour les relations
franco-espagnoles c'est une institution
qui a été fondée il y a plus de 100 ans
un lieu donc rempli d'hier soir il y a
eu des périodes un peu compliquées pour
ce lieu notamment après la guerre
d'Espagne oui alors effectivement 100
ans tout dépend un peu du point de du
point de départ
la Casa de Velasquez
officiellement en 1920 par Pierre Paris
un archéologue qui avait été membre de
l'École française d'Athènes et qui
venant en Espagne est tombé amoureux de
l'Espagne et il a du coup étudié les
l'affluences des Grecs en Espagne puis
les hivers et puis il a cherché à
reproduire ce qu'il avait connu à
Athènes pour s'implanter en Espagne il
était aussi amoureux d'art
il était directeur du de l'École des
Beaux-Arts de Bordeaux et il a donc
conçu cette idée très insolite pour
l'époque ce pari fou de créer à la fois
une école française à l'étranger donc
une résidence de chercheurs mais aussi
une villa Médicis il est il est passé
par la vie d'un Médicis comme tout les
archéologues de l'époque la vida Médicis
de Rome à savoir donc une seule maison
la Casa de Velasquez qui abrite dans son
projet et qui abrite encore aujourd'hui
des chercheurs et des artistes donc là
on est en 1920 fondations en 1928 est
inauguré la partie on va dire centrale
de la de la Casa de Velasquez ce patio
n'était pas encore construit donc
inauguration par le roi Alphonse 13 qui
était qui était très intéressé par le
projet et qui a cédé ce terrain
de deux hectares ou est implanté la
cassa des plus beaux espaces de la cité
universitaire alors en construction et
la Casa le bâtiment était terminé en
1935 donc cette ce patio alors il n'a
pas été vraiment terminé puisque faute
d'argent on n'a pas pu ouvrir la
quatrième enfin fermer la quatrième le
quatrième côté ce qui nous vaut
aujourd'hui une magnifique une
magnifique vue et en 1936 effectivement
la guerre civile et la partie centrale
le bâtiment central de la de la Casa de
Vélasquez va être très sérieusement
endommagée et la maison va être
construite en 59 selon un style plus
moderne un style italien précisément par
ce lieu c'est donc un lieu de chercheur
où les chercheurs se réunissent avec
notamment l'École des hautes études
hispaniques est-ce que vous avez un
exemple de recherche que l'on fait ici
alors École des hautes études
hispaniques c'est l'ancien nom donc qui
a été créé d'ailleurs un peu avant la
fondation de la Casa de Velasquez
aujourd'hui c'est l'École des hautes
études espagnoliques et ibérique qui
incluent donc tout ce qui est tout ce
qui concerne la péninsule à savoir
notamment le Portugal et puis le nord du
Maghreb et la dimension transatlantique
alors nous accueillons
environ une vingtaine de chercheurs pour
des résidences longues sur des projets
post doctoraux aujourd'hui et je vais
vous donner un exemple de recherche très
intéressante qui d'une personne qui va
être recrutée l'année prochaine qui est
pour moi assez emblématique de ce qui
est intéressant pour la Casa de
Vélasquez c'est une chercheuse poste
doctorale qui va travailler sur l'art
militant
des communautés indigènes du japas dans
le processus de patrimonialisation c'est
un art militant c'est pas
comme de l'art au sens traditionnel du
terme et elle va l'étudier à partir de
la politique d'acquisition du Rena Sofia
alors vous accueillez des chercheurs
mais aussi des artistes en résidence
soit sur un an soit donc à plus court
terme sur trois mois quels sont les arcs
que vous accompagnez Ici vous mettez
l'accent sur la pluridisciplinarité si
j'ai bien compris alors la
pluridisciplinarité est au cœur de
l'établissement tente dans la dimension
scientifique d'ailleurs que dans la
dimension artistique alors une
pluridisciplinarité qui est on va dire
relative dans la mesure où notre grande
marraine c'est l'Académie des Beaux-Arts
qui a présidé à notre fondation et du
coup avec les disciplines artistiques
qui sont représentées à l'Académie des
Beaux-Arts à savoir donc les arts
visuels le cinéma la photographie la
gravure le dessin mais nous avons ouvert
à travers des bourses en collab donc la
pluridisciplinarité liée à l'Académie
des Beaux-Arts c'est dans le cas des
résidences longues et dans le cas de
résidence courte nous avons élargi le
champ disciplinaire à d'autres à
d'autres disciplines au fur et à mesure
des années de façon à couvrir un spectre
extrêmement large et avoir pour cette
maison la possibilité de représenter
toutes les formes artistiques
contemporaines merci beaucoup Nancy
Berthier d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle donc vous êtes là directrice de
la Casa de Vélasquez ici à Madrid on
écoute maintenant une artiste en
résidence ici pendant trois mois qui a
bénéficié justement de la Bourse l'aine
et création une bourse en collaboration
avec donc le Mobilier national et
l'ADAGP elle s'appelle Sarah Viguier la
bourse l'année création qui qui est donc
un dispositif assez nouveau
je l'ai découverte par l'intermédiaire
d'une veille un petit peu active que je
faisais par rapport aux différentes
résidences proposées par la Casa la
Villa Médicis enfin je suis un petit peu
l'actualité de ces différentes de ces
différents lieux de résidence et pour la
première fois il y avait une résidence
qui s'intéressait vraiment à
au métier du textile en fait
et au métier d'art et donc
je me suis dit c'est peut-être pour moi
sachant que c'est très peu fréquent en
fait les résidences propres aux textile
et où on va dire le textile et pas
seulement considéré comme un artisanat
mais aussi comme le véhicule enfin ou le
médium pour aller vers de l'art ou de la
sculpture d'art ce qui est un peu le
projet que je propose dans le cadre de
cette bourse c'est un projet
autour d'une créature un peu étonnante
qui
est un peu folklorique mythologique en
Espagne en Espagne il y a un petit peu
en Italie aussi en fin dans différents
coins autour de la médaille qui
s'appelle le gamboucine et c'est une
créature en fait c'est un dispositif de
jeu
inventé par par des adultes pour occuper
les enfants souvent aux champs quand on
ramasse quelque chose ou dans une tâche
un peu révarbative et en gros on va on
va faire croire par tout un tas de
stratagèmes
à cette créature et donc l'enfant se met
à imaginer son embout sinon chaque
enfant a une image en fait un peu
particulière de cet être et ensuite il
faut donc on en a un peu peur parce que
les adultes se mettent à faire des cris
on nous montre un croc une nuit de
serpent une trace enfin et donc
on a peur et après
l'idée c'est d'aller chasser le grand
booster donc de de créer des outils de
chasse un peu voilà craft et d'aller
c'est une partie de chasse mais une
partie de chasse infinie parce
qu'évidemment cet être il existe pas et
en fait c'est un peu ce dispositif de
jeu que je transfère dans mon dispositif
de tissage d'une part parce que le
tissage j'en avais une part bleue c'est
technique c'est compliqué c'est une une
série d'étapes en fait
comment dire assez complexe à maîtriser
et donc il fallait un peu braver toutes
ces toutes ces peurs là et ensuite
ce gantoussinant je le je le tisse en
gros mon idée avec le tissage c'est que
c'est de me servir de ce savoir faire
plutôt de dimension pour aller vers de
la trois dimensions et pour aller vers
des sculptures autoportantes ou en
suspension
en me servant d'un matériau que j'ai mis
au point qui est un caoutchouc
[Musique]
biosourcés en fait ça m'a ça m'a pris
pas mal de temps et je me sers du
caoutchouc comme un peu mes muscles et
mes tendons pour gonfler ma structure
et de la laine comme la toison en fait
le duvet les poils de ma de mon gant
aussi non
[Musique]
le panel est un sport en plein essor en
Espagne selon la Fédération
internationale de paddle ils étaient
plus de 6 millions à pratiquer ce sport
en Espagne l'an dernier en 2022 on en
parle tout de suite avec Yannick il est
professeur de paddle
merci beaucoup de nous accueillir ici à
la Rio Arena padel des Madrid le paddle
c'est un sport je l'ai dit en plein
essor en Espagne ces dernières années
comment est-ce qu'on explique ce succès
et il dépasse quasiment le tennis il
dépasse le tennis sur les dernières
années
et surtout car il a beaucoup de
flexibilité dans le sens où tous les
âges peuvent jouer du plus petit jeune
aux personnes âgées c'est très facile il
ne requiert pas de temps que ça de la
forme physique comme
et en conséquence elle te reviendra
toujours c'est la principale différence
l'objectif du padel et des réussir à
monter au filet c'est à dire d'être ici
là pour pouvoir faire des volets parce
qu'il est plus facile de gagner le point
ensuite c'est la différence cette
puissance dans le tennis est beaucoup
plus importante et c'est ce que vous
devez sentir savoir quand il y a un coût
plus faible et quand vous pouvez en
profiter pour faire un smash plus fort
on échange quelques balles
[Musique]
donc
si bien très bien
[Musique]
si elle si elle aura
c'est terminé vous pouvez revoir cette
émission replay sur notre site Internet
ou sur notre application radio sensation
moi je vous dis à bientôt pour un
prochain numéro
[Musique]